teachers in Los Angeles they are
striking for the third day in a row in a
new poll nearly 80% of all residents
voiced support for educators among
parents with school-aged children
support was even higher at more than 82%
but some are starting to question how
the strike in the lost classroom time
will impact the students tonita copal is
outside North Hollywood Senior High
School where the teachers are
demonstrating again today Tony good
morning to you good morning well they're
expected to demonstrate a little early
here for now I've been noticing that
some of the teachers around the city are
wearing pins that say I walked the line
in 89 that's a reference to the last
time there was a strike here in LA that
one lasted nine days and parents and
teachers tell me they're ready for a
similar nine days again but the big
question is what if this strike lasts
longer you could say the family dinner
table at deira and Juneau pier Louis's
house is one of the newest public
schools in Los Angeles at least it's the
only one right now for six-year-old
Desai and eight-year-old nehe their
elementary school teachers are among the
30,000 on strike and while La schools
are still technically open with
substitutes Dara and Juneau are keeping
their kids home in solidarity so this is
about fairness for you guys yeah
equality equal chance yes cuz I'm good
here doesn't mean everyone else is good
three blocks away it's for the greater
good anyway it's worth it I mean what
like who are we who are we who matters
every single child should matter every
single child should have the chance to
have a good education that includes nehe
and acai who before the strike was
almost ready to read and these are
crucial days they're crucial days I mean
I was so close even when Christmas
breaking was like oh we're gonna lose so
much ground I am the most worried about
him it's really hard to supplement a
kindergartner and that's really tough
weight cuz he just was on that on that
breaking point of learning to read the
strike follows a demographic shift in
the district with many wealthy white
families opting for private schools the
district is now disproportionately low
income if this strike is not successful
what's
future of education for all these kids
you know I worry about that Gayle
Chicoine son goes to the same school as
a sigh and knee he but while parents may
worry there is at least one group that's
optimistic raise your hand if you think
public school as a future in California
I do have some good news for those kids
last night LA lawmakers voted to give an
additional ten million dollars for
nurses and mental health services
however that is still a far cry from uh
the teachers are demanding and some bad
news the strike in 1970 the strike
before the one in 89 that one lasted
nearly five weeks John Wow Tony thank
you